for most of the 20th century LGBTQ
people were forbidden from showing pride
in their sexuality they were forbidden
from being who they are but they fought
back against persecution police
brutality oppression this is the history
of pride in the United States in six
minutes
okay go throughout most of the 20th
century activities associated with being
anything but heterosexual and gender
conforming were against the law as an
increasingly visible gay culture began
to grow so did police raids of gay
spaces police force was used to suppress
the acceptance of the queer and trans
community and enforce a conservative
agenda dating back to the early 1900s
violent raids spread across America
especially in cities like New York San
Francisco and Los Angeles a popular
location to target were bars and bath
houses were gay people gathered over
time hundreds of people were arrested
and beaten just for existing within
these spaces since activities associated
with queerness were criminalized in the
1930s in what is now miami-dade County a
venue not unlike the spaces we have the
freedom to create and occupy today
existed la paloma nightclub was a space
for burlesque lake performances by both
women and female impersonators as well
as a space vert effeminate male
performers most of the staff and patrons
were queer and/or gender non-conforming
folks one of the club's visitors
described it as a scene for homosexuals
and evening gowns and trousered lesbians
as well as sex workers on a November
night in 1937 a group of nearly 200 men
and women associated with the KKK
stormed the nightclub violently
attacking the people inside while
dressed in their long white hooded robes
and burning their fiery cross later
local law enforcement conducted their
own rate of la paloma given the time
period it's likely that the same
authorities who raided as police had
already attacked all their identities
were concealed
with the KKK despite the violent
vigilante and police raids la paloma
reopened with new programming that the
manager described as by seer
Entertainment than ever and that's just
one example of the dozens maybe hundreds
of violent incidents that targeted the
LGBTQ community for decades leading up
to 1969 so what made the Stonewall riots
of 1969 such an iconic turning point for
gay liberation well in the 1960s the
West Village in New York City became
somewhat of a gathering place for gay
people and home to many underground gay
venues the Stonewall Inn was
particularly known for being a place
where trans people drag queens and
homeless queer youth could gather safely
it was considered a safe space not only
by the nature of being for queer people
but also because it gave young homeless
queer individuals a place off the
streets to be in the days leading up to
the riots tension between the NYPD and
the community was building a few days
prior police raided Stonewall harassing
the patrons their goal was to shut the
inn down the LGBTQ community was growing
tired of the brutality and impression
they were facing for simply existing in
the early hours of June 28 1969 police
raided the Stonewall Inn again leading
to the arrests of 13 patrons as the
patrons were being removed from the
venue a crowd gathered questioning the
police's authority resulting in violent
conflict many note a lesbian is one of
the first people to fight back against
the police that night with some
believing her to be stormy de la vie a
de la VA a biracial butch lesbian became
known to be something of a guardian to
lesbians in the city other prominent
figures in the uprising were Marcia P
Johnson and Sylvia Rivera Rivera was a
latina trans activist who was just 17 at
the time
Marcia P Johnson was an iconic figure in
the NYC trans community and the
Stonewall Riots that night in 1969 was
followed by six days of conflict and
protest
against the NYPD by the following night
the news of the riots spread quickly
across the city and a group of about
2,000 protesters began to gather what
occurred was a direct confrontation
between the police and protesters the
cops used fire hoses and threatened gun
violence while the crowd chanted and
sang for liberation further acts of
defiance involved the crowds holding
hands and engaging in other displays of
affection boldly as these could have
been considered criminal activities at
the time over all 21 people were
arrested during the riot within several
weeks the New York Mattachine Society
one of the earliest LGBT organizations
in the United States let a gay power
march throughout the city drawing a
crowd of hundreds Marsha P Johnson and
Sylvia Rivera went on to found star
Street transvestite action
revolutionaries an organization that
served to aid homeless and runaway trans
youths as well as other LGBTQ
individuals they also rallied against
racism sexual violence and transphobia a
year after the Stonewall riots on June
28 1970 the first pride parade was held
the first march gave the community a
chance to memorialize the uprisings that
had occurred on Christopher Street the
year before it's reported that the March
started with just a few hundred people
in downtown New York but swelled in size
as it made its way uptown toward Central
Park displaying gay pride at this time
was still a bold act and it said that at
the beginning of the March many were
worried about their safety so they moved
swiftly through the streets today pride
celebrates the strides the community has
made since that first public display of
gay pride in 1970 we march in June to
honor those who came before us and took
to the streets demonstrating against
centuries of abuse government hostility
and discriminatory laws
[Music]